Wow welcome to this video playing with
one minute less I had pressed the
five-minute button and then my doorbell
rang okay at least it's a closed
position and not some wild tactical meal
a meal a melly you know hand-to-hand
combat bleh the num okay so let's see it
didn't help all this it like so much the
street form okay let's see can I go F
for guy might put the night only five
but ok let's need to need to be a bit
bit quicker than usual I mean much
quicker than usual as a funny expression
as I'm not really good usually but you
know to try to catch up a bit ok well
let's dream scenario is 97 Bishop f6 and
something on e5 but not that's not so
it's so easy to accomplish
97 others maybe even light b5 just
attacking if I go nite b5 and intend to
take vigoss queen bee 6s even 3b3 yet
still I'm doing this come on intending
to take I don't see how he protects it
ah this way it's the idea but if I go
Queen a for now and isn't this good the
ship I don't see a defense against this
really just threaten to take now
very direct stuff but night g 6 i'm
taking d 6 he can maybe make a sacrifice
out of it yeah does the question is
should I can also take the rope here if
I play this he probably will probably
will just castle 96 is not really
working King King here and no move ok he
will castle I guess and now the question
is if I should take I probably shouldn't
maybe just retreat so that i have
ninety-seven available if he goes Bishop
d7 I play the Queen away it's a yeah
this is better than then taking 1e7 I'm
giving away the dark squares completely
you need to retreat and now at least um
he cannot easily play Bishop t6 maybe
you should even take b5 and play Bishop
t6 get rid of this Bishop get all this
one also not not without its points
intending Bishop b5
okay want to catch up here ok let's see
him taking now come on take and go here
to go to a five if it takes g4 I take b7
checking the Queen now I was thinking
thinking night f5 maybe first this one
checking the attacking of the night now
here yeah this looks ok I think I'm I
have sufficient control here it's an
still this problem with the the
excellent 90 of course but at least my
my king is not a problem which can
easily happen of course ok yeah it's not
that's not at all easy to play I should
have gone to a forum
this is not easy at all but as mentioned
it is sufficient sufficient control
playing against b5 and next I need to
should I go if I think I should he
cannot easily attack the pawn and it's
helpful look over to f4 maybe it's a
look at six
I guess I should transfer it here
controlling h5 now that's okay that's
really okay
look I want to have a look here okay
keeping the beef farm and contending
King a phone check this one probably
intending look b7 just trying to take it
yeah this is scott check
black resigns hmm cam complicated yeah
hehe was obviously pre moving here but
ok this is a better anyway I think who
yeah this was stuff especially
considering i had one minute less but i
got this pawn and after that it was it
was very tricky for black around here if
we concentrate on this in this spot are
interesting the computer just wants to
play this I thought that I could take
here but he's got a six interesting I of
course is good a six I can take here and
now King takes this is of course winning
but you can take with your King which is
really a bit crazy crazy but Sam this
piece no I can play something like that
with completely unclear consequences gee
I didn't see any of that of course it's
it's not not clear what happens i can
push this for example yeah this is this
is probably good young here he'd here
played Bishop f6 I thought here this was
interesting it leads to at least to a
comparable position to the game return
like this yeah here i have i have
control i think i could yep here maybe
the pawn yeah this was also good this
was a sodium and then look he won okay i
was maybe a bit to focus on catching up
on the clock
yeah I guess yeah yes yes chants to
blockade but it's um Roundheads I think
it's tricky maybe before was a bit to be
too quick but this is just just good I
think he cannot keep the blockade as a
combination of King f4 and later will be
six or Luke asics will probably win
kennel Tina cannot keep the night then
this means white should should really
win if i can get this night away from me
five and play 45 black shirt should
really lose ok thanks for watching